hey guys this is dennis the founder
thick hair and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the second
episode of season 4 of The Walking Dead
infected yeah lots of stuff happen in
here zombie outbreak rixton you know
back to being the chaera have a doctor
who broke down every single detail what
it is an information along so we know it
when it's causing a lot people expect
cleanings as the water and what's going
on now we know is some flu yeah some bad
virus yeah so let's just start off with
a zombie outbreak which is kind of like
the main thing of the whole episode is
you know that kid Patrick died last
episode from some sort of flu and and
like we know now it's like you cannot
just get turned into a zombie from being
bitten by a zombie you just die you turn
into a zombie right yeah which I mean
there's a part of the comic book didn't
do this here but you know Rick's like we
are the walking dead you know is this
realization that if you just die no
matter how you die or the heart attack
or your bidding like you're going to
turn your zombie no matter what
everybody is infected so it's like a
double infection yeah of course you're
infected with whatever is going on in
the world it makes you zombie you're
also infected from this this flu that's
been spreading which introduces us to
some new characters yeah just don't know
anybody's name of the two little cute
blonde girls and dad died and I don't
know what's going and then Carol's
calling when a week it was like your
week so somebody's got to tell you it's
like she's a little girl I give me Wow
yeah like Cara was we talked about know
right yeah but now like she has these
she has to be this mother figure to
these two girls who lost her father in
that uh outbreak so we'll see if that
relationship deepens you know more
because you know there was something you
know we saw with tyrese in the beginning
with his girl you know we really haven't
gotten into that relationships they've
shown little hints of that but now we
know that you know she's she's dead at
the end of the episode I wasn't know who
did it yeah because there's like he
doesn't know who we don't know who did
it because he saw like they were both
burnt with
ethylene and we also the mystery of
who's feeding the zombies and bringing
them in because there's a person with
the flashlight and the rats hmm we don't
know who's doing that and why like why
would you do that right and there's a
huge group of new people at the prison
right now from you know from the town so
we don't really know we're still meeting
new characters every week so who knows
who's who's doing what yeah so what do
you think of just the action overall
with with all the zombies coming in and
taking over the prison I mean it's cool
i mean they're The Walking Dead is does
a great job at set-pieces I mean the one
last week with zombies fall do you know
the helicopter coming down zombies fall
into something it's cool it looks good I
don't know how much do you have a story
it is from a storytelling perspective I
still think the walking dead struggles
with storytelling sometimes if like it
gets I don't I don't know it gets bogged
down and whatever it is it gets bogged
down and I it's it's good I just don't I
wasn't wrapped in this I wasn't into the
story this week but the set pieces are
great Greg Nicotero does an amazing job
with the special i mean like when that
guy was pushing his head through a fence
and like the UH and the guts fallen out
of the guy when he's rolling out of bed
I mean it looks great but um story-wise
I don't know I thought this episode was
maybe a little bit weaker than last
week's I thought well I think it was a
much simpler episode it was just about
the outbreak and how it affected
everyone now you have all these people
like quarantined you can't talk to this
person and talk to that person but I
guess one of the bigger developments in
it is Rick's relationship with the son
Carl and you know how Carl you know had
to use the gun to save Michonne and how
free you know was forbidding him to do
that but he gave his his gun back to
earth and and then sheriff put in it and
then Rick put on his little like he's
bad he's yeah the sheriff's back in town
he got his his little cop belt and his
gun so it looks like he's ready to do
battle what do you think of his decision
to kill the pigs in order to lure the
zombies away like they're not sure the
pigs are the read they're just
speculating right then the pigs could I
possibly be pagas you know like how like
Warren like birds pigs the doctor was
breaking down like that's how some of
these viruses are effective but I mean
it seems a little excessive like
couldn't just do one and like have a
little trail of college I know if you
were trying to catch a fish or something
instead of killing all their pigs I mean
that's that's a lot of pork dan that's
our dinner I don't think they need to
kill that many pigs but I guess you know
maybe they just don't want to risk it
and they don't they don't want to be
like here you try a piece and like let's
see what happens to you yeah I don't
know I mean I guess it's just weird i
don't know me what are you what's your
opinion on the story telling us these i
mean are you liking with his Troy's go I
dont still too early to opposition but
are you liking what the story's going or
um I think it's fine i just think it's
it's not too complex and that we really
i mean something like an outbreak or flu
it isn't as big as as they think it is
you know i ain't like don'tdon't uh it's
the flu you know and like we're you know
so yeah yeah IM curious so that was
interesting seeing that kind of a small
scene away from all the action but the
scene with Michonne and the baby maybe
throws up and shown just reluctant to
hold the baby and then she ends up
holding them starts just breaking down
and crying so I wonder if we get some
more explanation to you no more story
that Michonne's past and why that little
baby is so troubling to her lair time to
be the cries or whatever she just seems
to break down so this is more story of
that later I don't know they we do have
the mystery of the who who's feeding the
zombies and also who burnt the bodies a
probably the same person most likely and
they have to explain why this person is
doing doing it I think that's maybe
hopefully gonna be a driving force in
the next few episodes but at the same
time you can't carry that that oh yeah
not too far hopefully it'll get resolved
next week and then you know it's not
really sure what the main problem with
the main stories gonna be for the season
now is it gonna be the prison is it
gonna be the governor we know is still
there not be the flu I mean if you can
last like a couple episodes right I
don't want to see outbreak version of
you know walking dead but the flu can't
be like the main story point right from
here into the end of the seeds like oh
people becoming zombies you can't make a
flu the main yeah alright guys you can
post your comments below on our website
think Carol calm or on our YouTube
channel let's think
GoPro make sure you subscribe to that
also check us out on Twitter we're at
think here how to dentists myself
personally i'm at griffin de and we also
have facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash think carroll fans
you